Kalli is having a picnic for her six
friends the oldest friend Vikram is 10
years old the youngest diya
is 6 years old she has a total of 48
blueberries and wants to split them
evenly between her friends how many
blueberries does each friend get and I
encourage you to now pause this video
and try to figure it out in your own how
many blueberries does each friend get
let's think about this a little bit so
she has 6 friends she has 6 friends and
she wants them all to be able to get the
same amount so she wants to split the 48
blueberries evenly amongst her 6 friends
the ages of her friends don't matter so
she's going to take the 48 blueberries
she's going to take the 48 blueberries
and divide it and divide it by 6 she
wants to divide it into 6 groups so she
wants to divide it into six groups 48
divided by 6 and so this so question
mark is going to be equal to the number
of blueberries that each friend gets so
48 divided by 6 is equal to question
mark is the same thing as saying that 48
48 is equal to is equal to question mark
times 6 times 6 so if we can figure out
what number we can multiply by 6 to get
48 then we know what 48 divided by 6
actually is for example this question
mark this is the number of blueberries
per friend the number of blueberries per
friend times 6 friends well that should
tell us the total number of blueberries
which is 48 so what is this number well
let's think about let's just think about
all of the multiples of 6 so 6 times 1
is equal to 6 6 times 2 is equal to 12
and really we're just increasing by 6
each time we're just increasing by 6 6
times 3 is equal to 18 6 times 4 is
equal to 24 6 times 5 is equal
236 times 6 is equal to 36 6 times 7 is
equal to 42 notice we're just adding 6
every time 6 times 8 is equal to 48 it's
equal to 48 so we now know that question
mark we now know that the question mark
must be 8 6 times 8 and 8 times 6 is the
same thing so this is going to be equal
to 6 times question mark 6 times
question mark and now we learned that
question mark is equal to 48 I start a
question mark is equal to 8 so each of
her friends are going to get 8
blueberries so this is right over here
48 divided by 6 is equal to 8
blueberries
now let's verify that we have 48
blueberries right over here let's divide
them into 6 groups where each group is
going to have 8 blueberries so let me do
my best so let's see this is 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 so that's a group of 8 blueberries
see here's another group of 8
blueberries right over here and here's
another group right over here of 8
blueberries and then here's our fourth
group of 8 blueberries and now let's see
we can make a fifth group of 8
blueberries fifth group of 8 blueberries
and then finally here is our sixth group
here is our sixth group of 8 blueberries
so notice we have six groups of eight
blueberries
each of her six friends could take one
of these groups of eight blueberries